do you ever get like holy [ __ ] man I
played Superman and now I'm on a show
when I'm playing you know a big
character who's I don't want anybody to
see like the vulnerability to the side
of me that they'll be like oh he's not
capable of playing this role he can't
handle it if they if you see any
weakness you know do you ever feel like
that or have you in years where I no
matter how nervous you are or exhausted
or whatever it is you just suck it up
and pretend that you're absolutely
fantastic I don't think I always suck it
up and pretend that I'm absolutely
fantastic if I'm tasked with that in an
interview and to go on and promote
something yes I will I will do that but
I mean what you're asking is multiple
answers and pen and aspects I didn't do
that question yeah I would say that the
end of my run as Superman in Superman
Returns that did not that that that did
not pan out the way I thought it was
going to the way everyone around me
thought it was going to and so I had to
really come to terms with a lot of that
I mean there was no sequel you know the
movie was widely well reviewed people
like to see like the movie but it you
know made almost 400 million dollars
worldwide but that wasn't enough and it
was a very slow fizzle out of the
possibility of a sequel over the next
2-3 years and I did my I did everything
I could do that I thought in my in mmm
in my world to help make it happen
which is a story for another time or
this time uh but war to mental health
and we should go back if we want on that
but you know I I think at that point in
my life I still didn't know that I had
that I was anxious that I had that what
anxiousness really was or that I had it
that anyone could experience anxiety
yeah did you believe it I mean you
believed that we just did you ever see
anxiety or see I don't think I let it in
you know there's a there's a whole thing
about
go back and look at my childhood
anybody's childhood and we all grew up a
certain way believing certain things and
seeing the world in their way and I
pretty much saw rainbows and hearts and
rainbows and made everything that I
didn't want to be that wasn't hearts and
rainbows into hearts and rainbows it's
called bypassing right so I grew up in a
culture of bypassing spiritual bypassing
using God or using something else to
Aaron's good yeah it's gonna it's gonna
be okay because just give it to God and
and it will you know everything will be
okay because of that right which is if
Harry can be very calming right it's oh
wait is it like okay don't worry about
this but but that catches up to you
eventually right because then you're
only living life in in white and life is
black and white you can't have one
without the other
right it's essential for life yeah and
you know through through multiple career
experiences and showing me that I have
an opportunity to learn more and through
my wife Courtney Ford who's you know
been an amazing help that guide in in
finding balance and she was with you
through that whole thing yes she was
with you if she if you didn't have her
when you had Superman Returns right yeah
because you met her in 2002-2003 3 yeah
but you know I always think how do you
get through things yeah there's so many
things death you know you're supposed to
be on the sequel's and then that didn't
pan out yeah and if you don't have
anybody to vent to or really go deep and
be vulnerable and real and you just
deflect like fine I'm fine go out drink
or I'll go out and party you're just
prolonging the inevitable what's
happening is distraction distraction
distraction and all of a sudden three
years later or two years later a month
later you start to feel things and you
don't even know where they came from but
why don't I feel this why did I get so
upset about that why was my response to
and you have no idea then it's lost in
translation you don't even know why
you're upset and you then through
whatever therapy or you realize it's
coming for all four
that all these things that I kind of
tucked away yes I mean that's that's
what I found so it's nice that I you
know I was doing some reading and I do
that occasionally but um reading but
just I noticed Courtney was the theme
the Courtney was the sort of the running
theme that was just like hey see how
important she is to you